ce qu'ils vivent
c'est mon frère est osé car ça y est un
film tout ce que vous voulez que les
bonnes feuilles fruits coupés
s'il vous plaît coupe aux états une
table ronde pour faire mon tour des
quartiers
regardez il fait moins tous les quatre
ans
non mais franchement et koudrine
mais écoutez gars est paru ce moteur qui
aurait fait deux tours canons à l'essai
pour un troisième tour à bâle face on
fait de la non parce qu'il n'est pas
assez à l'écouté nous avait écoutés
allez vous reposer
ah et si on se retrouve ce qui leur
donne vraiment alors en détail on avait
le kaléidoscope vers côté à 2009 aux
pros et l'énigme à 2002 que tu avais
vraiment et c'est toute la journée comme
ça chez chaque samedi
alors